so nixon
at the time when he did it okay did he
have
enough intel about this country or was
china an innocent
nation to like listen i think this can
be a good opportunity for the country
what would you say about
look at the time china was a backwater
and we were concerned about the soviet
union so the whole point of nixon going
to china was really
to take down the soviet union so at the
time it made strategic sense
what didn't make sense is that fast
forward from 1972 to 1989
and you have tienem square george h.w
bush is now the president george h.w
bush could have stopped this china at
that time less than a trillion dollar
economy
right still a backwater they'd gotten
some technology from us but we could
have
cut him off there no what did he do he
sent brent scrowcroft back
the national security advisor back on a
secret mission to china in august
there's pictures of him shaking hands
with deng xiaoping in beijing
and so what happened we basically said
um you know
soviet union was collapsing you know
eastern europe was becoming democratic
tiananmen square happened the chinese
communist parties so what they did
the the party leadership and this is
revealed in in documents
called the tiananmen papers so what
happened was the communist party
leadership got together they've been
studying what's going on with the soviet
union glasnost perestroika and they're
saying
uh we don't like it but we don't like
this and we're seeing the collapse of
the soviet union
and we don't want that to happen to us
so there's three things that they
that they come to the conclusion in this
in this enclave and there's in the tn
papers is really speeches that they're
giving like
communist party leadership is giving to
each other at zhong nanghai which is
kind of their leadership enclave
and they say three things one they say
tiananmen is not about our students
tiananmen the americans
caused this the americans are causing
the uprising tendon which was totally
number two we need
the americans we need uh we need
technology we need innovation we need
talent and we need most importantly we
need capital we need money
and and so we have to stay open to them
but but we
can't allow democracy or democratic
ideas to come into the country so we
have to build a system
to prevent that and number three if the
party ever becomes separated from the
people
that we will lose so from from june
4th 1989 on the party makes a pivot
and we basically keep playing the same
game even though the
soviet union's disintegrating so at that
point is really where i
say we we made a big mistake it's not
nixon
um now who profited from that
trip in 1972 kissinger did and kissinger
has long been
the voice to american presidents about
how to deal with china
go look at how much money kissinger has
made from the chinese communist party
and then you'll start to understand how
much
millions millions in what ways
he gets access to the white house
is he saying feedback that benefits
america long term
or does he is he giving his care so and
this is this is the way the
the party does it just like i said she
goes to davos
he's carrying the message of the party
to the president right this is
so if you deal with the chinese in this
way there'll be much they'll be much
easier to deal with
right so let me give you an example
when i when i got to the pentagon and i
was so starting to be trained as a
military diplomat because i was going to
go to
be the defense attache i started you
know
starting to work with the diplomatic
corps and starting to understand what we
were saying
what are our policy statements to um the
chinese communist party what are our
talking points
and i started and i also had to work
with the people's liberation army which
is
the the chinese communist party's armed
military
and i'm talking to the pla guys and then
i'm talking to my own diplomats and i'm
talking to the pla guys i'm talking to
my own diplomats and i'm like
these guys are saying the same thing
these guys are
why are these guys saying the exact why
aren't these guys saying something
different
and that's when i realized that they the
chinese communist party
had basically captured the narrative and
so what the way they do
that is by using academics in the united
states
who are considered chinese experts to
deliver the talking points of the
chinese communist party
so if you understand how policies made
in dc these academics are called on
by the state department by the
administration tell us about china you
you go to travel to china a lot
you talk to the chinese communist party
officials what's the best way to deal
with china
and the academics will say well you need
to do this and the chinese communist
party is saying you need to do this
let me ask you a question when kissinger
is having those meetings with the
chinese communist party and is relaying
that information back to the u.s
is kissinger having those meetings
privately by himself or is anybody from
the team of the white house accompanying
campaign no no it's him
so right so him by himself it's him by
himself or he his people no no no
there's no government people there this
is and this by the way this happens at
all
all the time wait wait wait a minute
wait a minute so so you mean to tell me
kissinger goes and negotiates on behalf
of us no no no
no no he goes over and he has meetings
and
what is his role at the time when he's
doing this just as a private citizen
right so so so the way he makes money is
by consulting for for corporations for
chinese corporations and other um
and us corporations mostly u.s
corporations who are trying to work in
china but also
uh some there is some china and he goes
over and they just have discussions you
know how's the relationship going you
know between beijing and washington dc
you know how can we make it better we
want to make it better because we want
to have better business right we want to
yeah we want everybody getting along and
then and then the chinese communist
party said well if the
if if you could just get the
administration to do this
then everything would be great that's it
i get that so are you saying that when
he was doing that china was paying him
off to
no no no he's getting paid by other
companies but
how does he get into china how does he
get to see xi jinping how does
how does china trust henry does does
china trust kissinger
yeah because he's the delivery
delivering their message who
who is he in in in uh i guess what i'm
trying to find out is
who is he trying to protect more u.s or
china or
his own pockets well i mean you'd have
to ask him but i would say he's
he's been he's and and this is still
alive
he is so um this is a conversation
me and my wife had like okay i'm going
to take this path and i'm going to be
very
clear about who i am and what i stand
for and
and that's one path the other path that
people like me
take when they leave office is to take
the path of kissinger which is i'm going
to go consult for companies i'm going to
like like lieberman who does he talk uh
who does he console for
zte right there's a lot of them
lieberman yeah
uh who does uh uh admiral i can't
remember
anyway one of the one of the four stars
um chairman of the joint chiefs who does
he console for huawei
so you know that's a way that you can
basically take your time in government
and
and basically become very very wealthy
and that is how
for the most part the last you know 30
years are
people that senior leaders leaving the
us government
four stars state department officials
um uh here's a good one um ambassador
bacchus
you know the ambassador um he he's
basically now
he if you go watch him go watch his
talking points it's the same talking
points as a chinese communist party this
is what's going on so
so when you say i don't know anything
about china whenever you hear something
about
china what message are you hearing who's
talking
the chinese communist party is talking
what's the face
the face is a senior respected american
who is considered to be a china expert
yeah first of all i would do a couple
things here number one
uh if you work for the u.s government
you have to sign the ultimate
non-compete
that you cannot work for xyz for 20
years
you just can't i'm not going to put you
in a government position
in the u.s why would i put you in the
mail but hold on
what if nike comes and hires you i want
you
i want you to make sure that relations
between the two countries are good so i
can sell nike's no no what i'm trying to
tell you is you can't get a job
where your role has to do with the
following countries
and and improving those relations with
those countries you can't you don't want
the job don't get the job
but but i'm gonna tell you why why am i
gonna compromise the future of america
for your pockets
look there's a couple things here too
that's what dc is so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you